Wick is not a Rizzler. He's not a ladies man. I am pretty sure
the only that the only time that guy is when he's like answering
an ad on Craigslist for like one of 20 people that's going to
come and like this dog or something. Something very off about
that guy. >> I have to say I know he's a idiot. I know
he's always been an idiot. I know it's always been a misnomer
that he's smart, but I genuinely believe that the ketamine is
destroying his brain. I think he's doing too much ketamine. He's
doing too too many drugs. And uh >> I mean you throw Vinance
in there, we don't know who he's talking about or sorry, we could
be talking about
>> These these absurd cope sessions where Dan just comes
back on to try and reset Zogbox's programming and just get him
back on. Oh yeah, Hassan Hassan is really Hassan's really causing
all this when you think about it >> about this with CNN
senior political >> Okay,
so Trump basically doubles down. Doesn't say anything bad about
Pam Bondi. I'd say a lot of the people on the right that I've
seen have basically said, "Okay, I don't know what I'm talking
about." Right? I've seen quite a few people actually getting
upset about this or annoyed about this. No reason to even talk
about hate speech in this context. So, I I think for the most
part, the right-wing reaction has not been as bad as I would
would have thought it could be.
>> It's insane
when people blame Bondi for >> Wait, go ahead. Sorry. Say
that again. Also, I had to fix Discord real quick. It's insane
sweeping when people just blame Bondi for this. >> Oh,
do you mean like you should obviously see that she takes direction
from Trump and anything she's doing is she's just a shield for
Trump. >> Yes. Yeah. And she they've been talking about
hate speech since before they got elected. There's been like
there was like that clip of >> was it Vance or Trump walking
those [__] rabbis and they're talking about Yeah.
Yeah. Hate speech is like a real terrible thing. >> I mean
this is straight up downstream of the stuff they've been doing
around anti-semitic speech, right? Like it's it's the same path.
Yeah. Yeah. Sure. >> Yeah. And like even Trump there, he's
like, you know, they're coming up I feel like the line is pretty
clear. It's just they're not using hate speech to just mean when
you're rude to a minority. They're now saying it's it's when
you're just when you're just too rude. You know, hate speech
is when you're too hateful. When you're being too hateful of
someone. So when you say Trump's a fascist, when you say Trump's
a fascist, that's really hateful. That's really hateful for you
to say about Trump. So you can't say that anymore. That's clearly
the line this is going down. And anyone that's getting on Twitter
being like, "Oh, Pam Bondi's [__] everything up."
It's like you are on board with what she's saying. You just don't
want it to be called that because it makes you look [__]
>> on uh the other side of that would just be when I call
you a demon, I you know, I'm just concerned for kids. I'm just
I'm really worried about the kids. So I call you a demon. I'm
not trying to get you killed or anything. I'm just like expressing
a genuine concern. When I say you're a demon who uh stays stays
young by harvesting a drug from the blood of scared babies, when
I when I say you're doing that, when I say you're you're that
person, that's actually me just um I just kind of feel that way.
So, you can't stop me saying that, >> dude. It's it's a
lot. Uh
it's a lot. It's a lot right now. And the sad thing is is all
these people, I don't think you can do this, okay? You can't
do this and go, "No, Pam, Pam, Pam, that's like free speech."
And you can't take away our free speech. And then all of those
people are like, "Yeah, actually the FBI needs to arrest Hassan
and Destiny right now. Right now. This is in like you pick one.
Pick either you stand with with Pam or you stand with like free
speech. This is Pam and the administration."
>> Dude, dude, you know how funny Logan Box's streams are
right now. Last two days. Uh you talk about the uh the the saltman
the thumb get put on the scale
>> these these absurd cope sessions where Dan just comes
back on to try and reset Zogbox's programming and just get him
back on. Oh yeah, Hassan Hassan is really Han's really causing
all this when you think about it like Lo Box sitting there. It's
so funny as well. Loner box and Hutch have both independently
come up with their own their own snark left terms. Uh Loner Box
says the barnacle left now. He started saying this, the barnacle
left. So Hutch says the the black pill left. Wonderbox says the
barnacle left. And they're both talking about the same group
of people and complaining about the same thing for the exact
same reason, but they they're not using the same term. And they're
absolutely refusing to use uh the funny >> Um yeah, don't
give Why would they give you guys power? That's you don't refer
to them by their actual name. Yeah. Why would you do that? You
just laugh at >> It's not even me they're talking about.
They're talking about like, you know, they're talking about like
Hassan and the Vanguard and whatever the [__] >> channels
channels Destiny doesn't like. >> You think it's that much?
You think it's that simple? >> Well, yeah, it's that simple.
Because if it's not explicitly because they've got a kind of
latent parasocial buyin with with a stream that they watched
for years, then it's because ultimately their ideology is all
downstream from watching that streamer for years. >> I
don't think that's what it is. I think I think it's actually
just the audience. I think it's the audience capture. I think
that audience audience capture >> I think it's the audience.
I think it's the audience more than anything else because a lot
of those people will take like Destiny's talking points and they'll
go and they'll look up. It's like all the people who used to
get Destiny like on his like on the right page for the things
he was saying, right? Will go to like other streamers and be
like, "No, no, you're wrong on that. Look, here's the thing."
And they constantly shape. I feel like they constantly do this
shaping like over hours, like dozens of hours a week, over months.
But when I go into box stream, it seems like a lot of his people
these days are more skeptical like the son. >> I possibly
I don't think that was it. >> Not not the audience at large,
but I feel like you know the the the
moderators community members if you know what I mean. Same. >> Well,
I see a lot of the names I recognize from here to be honest with
you. Um >> well maybe >> I feel like I see Mew Crusty.
Mew Crusty, you're not in there all the time. You got like a
different name on YouTube, but I feel like I know it's you. Am
I crazy? They hate Destiny except David. See that? I know Maruti
hates David. I know there's a lot of the mods who don't like
Sorry, not hates David. Didn't mean that. Hates Destiny. >> We
all hate David. Everyone hates David. >> I didn't I was
just saying Maruti didn't say it. That's all. What is What did
you just link me? Porter Beller man isn't afraid to say Snark
left. Hold on. >> I think Wick said it earlier. Yeah, I
think it's probably linking. >> That's what it That's what
it is. >> That was a Kathy Wick calling.
>> Oh, was there? Oh, there's a couple things that I thought
were gonna be interesting today, but I hadn't gotten to. Um,
>> let's do them. It's so early. >> It is early.
Uh, I need those guys. Who cares about Oh, hold on. Hold on.
Is it right here? >> [__] those guys. Who cares
about the >> We got here.
>> Quan, do you know why that Prime Guy panel got shirtless?
>> No, I I didn't watch it. I just Someone sent me a screenshot
and I went and double checked it was real. was on AI filter or
something to make them all shirtless. I was like, "Wow, okay,
that actually happened." >> Okay, nobody's ever going to
find out >> Did you Did either of you watch the nonfun
dating advice panel?
>> dude. That was so funny. That was like such kino, man.
>> Do you remember the very very skinny guy from the shirtless
stream? The bottom middle cherry? That guy did like a dating
panel thing with Wick? >> With Wick. Wick is a love maker.
Love >> Yeah. Yeah. It's like a It was like a a rez panel
like not not doing like not like a dating panel but it was like
to >> it was like wick and a bunch of women try and explain
to nonfod how he can stop being a incel you know. >> Well
what happened? >> Uh I hate when you do this. >> It
did not go well.
>> J does this thing where he likes to pretend that other
people are not exactly what I say they are. Wick is not a risler.
He's not a ladies man. I am pretty sure the only that the only
time that guy is when he's like answering an ad on Craigslist
for like
one of 20 people that's going to come in like this dog or something.
Something very off about that guy. Feel like I feel like somehow
that's like probably accurate, but somehow in my head I feel
like that applies way more to Connor than it does to Wick. >> And
it's not because of anything he says. just because of like how
he
>> I'm telling you I'm telling you it's the way he like
>> having no morals can't have zero zero morals and like
he'll like profess these morals and then he will not stick to
them and it's just like somehow in my head I'm like dude you
don't hate
look at what you do look at look at who you surround yourself
with what do you mean you hate what do you mean degeneracy is
ruining America [__] you talking about Conor's >> fight
while he sits there and paints those little action figures something
so [__] weird about I what I will say is 100% Connor
would never cheat on his wife with another woman. >> That
I 100% believe that.
>> I don't know what Okay, but what aren't you saying?
That's that's what needs to be explored right now. >> Uh
I've made my position clear. Yeah. >> Yeah. Okay.
>> There's a lot of things you'd be cool with. Oh man.
Did you watch uh did you get a load of that techone video?
See that? >> I skimmed through it. I haven't streamed today.
today. >> It's uh it's pretty good.
>> Oh, lazy. >> I stream my last seven days in a
row. >> Kind of weak, but okay. What else am I looking
for here? I'm going to keep pulling up tweets here of random
[__] happening. Oh, the Elon Musk tweets are [__]
stupid. >> Did you see the the baby music video?
>> Yep. Watch that [__] >> Oh my god.
So funny. That's like actually some Mark Wahberg. It's like Mark
Wahberg [__] like when he was like >> if I
was in that plane I would Yeah. Also Tom McDonald. Yeah. Wait,
did you see Tom McDonald's Dear Charlie song or whatever it was
or whatever it's called? Yeah, that was so bad.
>> I will say uh J had to pause almost died when what is
it? The baby's hand just like grabs. >> Yeah, I lost it
watching that. I was losing it. >> I think it was based
on a true story.
>> I think the ending was different.
>> That actually just made me realize the best part of
the techone video. You saw that he references food shops.
>> I'm not joking. Hold on. >> Oh, no.
>> This guy is like This guy's like the most man alive.
And I say that knowing that Destiny exists. >> Heckon is
the most man alive.
>> When you like food shops occupies some
>> mental real estate for you to the point where you're
like mentioning her in a
>> That's uh that's rough. that picture that he posted
on Twitter. He trying to be the one who now though. >> How
long is that gonna uphold? >> Till somebody finds out anything
bad about him. Soon as somebody posts like one of his court documents
that basically he admits to doing something bad, he'll be back
in this mode again.
>> Why that I'm after I myself have been raped twice and
>> I've seen Tecton get wrecked way more than twice. >> Dude,
I I understand this this trauma response to seeing Hassan on
a screen anywhere. Okay.
It's uh it's [__] up. So, hold on. I just I I got
to play this. Okay, we got to just watch this this quick clip.
>> By the way, there's this one really ugly political I
can't tell if you're a guy or a girl. I really got no idea. I
don't even know what your name is, but you react to every single
one of my videos. >> So, can you just say like, are you
a boy or a girl? I really can't tell. It's It's this one like
it's like this one ugly troglodite. Sorry, this buddies. He's
eating rocks. There's this one really ugly like trogodite like
hobgoblin. You look like kind of Asian and you always react to
my videos and I always look at this and I'm like what the [__]
is that? >> Can you just clarify what the You're so ugly.
I can't even
say anyway. Kenny's here for the pedophile victory moment as
always. >> I mean I've been supporting food for the longest
time. I just want to say I'm so
>> Are we sure that that's >> Wait, can you send
me this time? No, that's 100%. Can you send me a time st? >> She
doesn't look kind of Asian.
She absolutely looks Asian. >> Well, you got to remember
Tekk's been playing gotcha games, so his view on Asian is kind
of off. >> Okay, I got you. That actually makes >> It's
like Asian fetal alcohol syndrome at the same time. The first
case ever. Usually these parents are very controlled when they're
when they're pregnant. But
um he's right about everything else though. I mean, he's not
wrong. He's just uh
like you don't react to like you're like seeing like crazy. Yeah.
The thing is that food chops is like >> it's not just that
food chops is like a nobody. It's that the criticism is so like
if you watch one of the videos it's almost impossible to even
tell what a point is most of the time. Uh and it's only being
spoken to the same small group of DJs. So it's just in by no
metric, not by audience, not by like substance,
uh not by like persuasiveness
is it should it even bother it shouldn't even like come into
your mind really that food shops criticism. But no, Tech Tone
decides to spend, you know, a full like 20 seconds, 30 seconds
talking about it in a video that's going to get half a million
views.
>> Yeah.
Yeah.
Um
Oh, man. Also, like I realized this at some point, I do believe
that almost all of their points, I think they actually aren't
really like thinking most of the time. They're just playing their
game and they'll read like a chat message that gives them like
a thought and they'll say it >> and then they'll have like
a totally dising different chatter, but like no, but then they'll
have like a different thought later from a different message
and they'll like undercut their first point like horribly. Like
they have no coherent like worldview or >> like the the
the mind is like not actually constructed in any You can you
can see even with like the Destiny stuff where you know they
will try and pay attention a little bit. It's still it's only
paying attention in so far as trying to figure out what the destiny
argument is, right? That's that's all she's ever trying to do
is is figure out what what the destiny argument is so it can
be repeated like as much as >> Uh yeah, I think that's
pretty accurate that they are trying to
they they say as much though sometimes they'll be like wait how
do I sweep for Destiny on this? Wait, how do I best sweep for
Destiny on this? And they'll say if if you guys want an argument
to defend Destiny, here's the argument. This >> see here.
No night owls. Kenny, don't don't lie about who you are. Kenny,
what are you doing?
>> Don't lie about who you are. Don't do it. What do we
got here? Oh,
>> a quick we could do a quick Kyle Klinsky video. He did
a good video here.
>> So Elon Musk, he did a good video here. >> Is
truly in the midst of an absolute legendary crash out. I do find
it funny that despite, you know, how Destiny constantly on this
guy and his wife, he'll still show up like pretty consistently
and defend Destiny on on like matters of free speech or whatever.
Like I think he had Dusty's back on the free speech almost entirely.
>> You said it's just the right position is what you said,
right? >> It is. Yeah, it is. There's literally I guarantee
you that there are a lot of people because I know I feel it.
I'm like, I don't want to defend this guy. I don't want to say
that he's like right cuz he's not right. He's like actually
>> he's like uh he's like the Westboro Baptist Church people
and I have to sit here and be the uh not the is it the >> I
already uh >> I don't even know what that is. >> I
braced myself for this months ago when people were like oh over
the Hassan stuff people were like oh well you would just want
Destiny thrown in jail no matter what. And I was like no no if
Destiny was going to get thrown in jail for a speech I would
say the same. So, I already braced myself months ago for the
idea that I might have to at some point make good on that and
defend people trying to put him in prison. >> I still go
out of my way to say like, "No, he's like a total degenerate.
He's like a horrible person. He's like a >> I just say
he should be put in prison for other things." Like there are
other things he should be put in prison for, just not this, you
know? >> Yeah. Also, like in terms of deplatforming, it's
like I think there are other things he could be deplatformed
for in terms of So, this is what gets him on breaking to. Like
I feel like even if it's on the line or something, I'm kind of
It's fine. Guess he deserves prison time for things not related
to his speech. Exactly. Substance. Yes. Yes.
But Kyle Kyle can see through it all. Okay. He uh he says >> Um
I have to say I know he's a idiot. I know he's always been an
idiot. I know it's always been a misnomer that he's smart, but
I genuinely believe that the ketamine is destroying his brain.
I think he's doing too much ketamine. He's doing too too many
drugs. And uh >> I mean you throw vinance in there, we
don't know who he's talking about or sorry we could be talking
about somebody the same guy situation, >> but he is talking
about ketamine. He's talking about it's making him dumber. It's
making his IQ drop by the minute >> and uh that's why you
see the the world's richest man is goostepping and zigiling on
the on the timeline on a daily basis and nobody even pays attention
to it anymore. All right, so let's walk through some of this
stuff. This guy Steve Steven Steven Barrett says, "The greatest
lie of our time is pretending that National Socialists
uh were right-wing. All socialists are leftwing." I saw a response
to this the other day that I really liked and it was a picture
of a urinal and it said, "All right, bro. Dig in." Cuz that's
a urinal cake.
I guess it's a cake, right? I guess uh North Korea is the Democratic
People's Republic.
That's what it says in the name, Democratic People's Republic.
Are we really having this debate in the year of our Lord 2025?
Are there really people out there saying that no actually truly
is like Steven Crowder made this? >> Maybe this is the
wrong video. I might have grabbed the wrong video. I was looking
for in like 2010 and everybody laughed him out of the room and
now he got the world's richest man soon to be a trillionaire
by some estimates. This man's out there like was a leftwinger.
The whole point of being leftwing is egalitarianism and equality
and justice and treating everybody fairly and giving them a shot,
right? The whole point of was exclusion and derision and a literal
racial hier. >> This is all fine, but I was looking for
the video of him talking about um oh something else entirely
like him talking about them arresting or not arresting but um
firing people over Charlie Kirk. Anyway, I'm which by the way
ironic cuz of course Elon Musk believes in eugenics and a racial
a rigid racial hierarchy. You're a lot closer to and by the way
you zigiled at the inauguration.
So you Zig Hild, but somehow the left are not. Explain that one
to me. I guess it depends on how deep he is in his ketamine hole.
If he's going to praise him on the day or pretend like the lefties
are hit on the day. I don't know. I guess it depends on that,
right? Jesus Christ, bro. He's in his 50s, right? Isn't he in
his 50s? And you're saying I had to say Kyle's power level drops
substantially when he's indoors. He He does way better with his
eyehand imitation videos. Okay. You guys notice that, by the
way, that everybody's imitating Peter Zahan at this point. They're
all doing like the walking and talking or like the outdoor videos.
They're like, "I have to live my life." >> His car videos
are his highest power level videos. Carlo,
>> they're great. It's always like super sunny. He's just
chilling in the car. It's like, "Yeah, I was uh I was at the
beach. I had to come out and shoot this video." Okay, guys. Israel,
you're not going to believe this. The USA just bombed Iran's
nuclear facilities. He's like in his car with the sun with the
uh sun visor down. >> Yeah. Well, it's because the whole
lighting thing, the LED lighting's behind you. It looks so stupid
now. >> I hate I hate these rooms, dude. That Metatron
guy, his room and AB's room as well. AB from
Disgusting.
I hate that. >> What decade are you in? >> You should.
Yeah. >> Oh man, you just reminded me of the Medatron thing.
I do. I don't have anything more to add there because I don't
really know about stream aesthetics or like camera aesthetics
that much, but uh
that Medatron guy's video on Hassan kind of sucked like really
badly actually. >> Yeah, dude. That guy's like a total
log out. I I saw a I saw a bad empanada video about that guy
like three months ago. Um it was really funny. Uh yeah, >> I
just thought it was so weird that Dan propagated that video and
the guy's like, "A Destiny's next after this." And I'm like,
"Why is Dan why is Dan putting this video out here?" >> It's
a little little weird. Um but all Yeah. So people are going after
Hassan.
I think the the clip that got really popular is from three years
ago. It's clearly about a debate and not about actually gutting
the opponents.
You gotten anybody doing substantial push back against that?
What is the what is the line like you can't use violent rhetoric
in uh
what would you call it like in
vivid ways? You just can't use violent rhetoric at all. Talk
about politics. I'm not sure what the >> I mean that that's
what people are running with now I guess. But I mean
it it's nonsensical obviously. I I don't even see anyone trying
to defend you anymore. I literally don't see who trying to debate
at this point. >> It's just I'm going to get as many clips
that like sound a little bit bad of you guys and we're going
to get more up votes on Twitter and then we'll win. and what
the truth is. So, who cares? All right. This guy talked about
having a knife. It's bad. It's not just lefties, Joe, bro. It's
not just lefties. It's like anybody who's going against
I don't know. It's like the all Twitter is right now. I don't
know. This whole thing's been a little goofy. The Destiny thing
I think is that was way worse.
Like I don't know. He's like out here straight up saying um
like essentially doing blackmail.
Like actually just being like, "Yeah, I'm not I'm not going to
disavow until they fix it." I I don't understand the
what would you call it? He constantly talks about game theory.
It's like the game theory of that position is like you just look
bad. You're like actually just losing every time. It's not I
mean it's not the prisoners dilemma.
>> Where's Where's the militia? Where where's the militia?
Put together the militia and then you can hold this position.
Okay. >> It's it's just Yeah, it's just goofy. He keeps
talking about game theory like all the time. I'm He did site
the prison. I know he cited the prisoners dilemma. It's not a
symmetric position though. It's silly. Uh
oh, I I had a whole bunch of tweets as well. There's just people
showing out about the Destiny clips from that thing. This is
the mainstream of the Democrat party. I did see unfortunately
a bunch of people were celebrating. Bunch of right-wingers got
kind of humiliated celebrating that Destiny was banned when he
was banned on Twitch in like 2023.
>> Yeah, they run that on Fox. >> Yeah, I know. You
was on Fox News. I did. I did. We got You cover this on stream,
Quan. Did you get a chance to cover this stuff? the panel.
>> Yeah, I covered the panel.
>> What' you think? >> Uh, Destiny's positions. Obviously,
it
>> like he has for some reason forgotten the art of it's
bad. What do you want me to say? >> The best part was after
like 40 minutes of being bered, he kind of does say there's no
excuse for political violence ever, like after the fact. >> So,
like he he puts out 40 minutes of like clips of him being like
a complete
just to give a point over anyway. Yeah. Uh it's
>> it's like l take this position and start army up and
getting your squad of DGS together to go and I don't know do
whatever you need to do or just say it's bad but
you guys suck. you know that that's cuz you're going to get he's
going up given this point a bunch of times anyway cuz like the
way he ends up giving it is like Andrew Wilson asks him like
an adjacent question that isn't quite is it justified or do you
disavow he's like do you feel bad about it or something he's
like yeah of course I feel bad about it is that you're always
going to end up slipping up on one of these questions because
you're not going to want to own like yeah I'm grinning that Charlie
Kirk's dead >> dude he um I I did think it was funny that
Andrew Wilson tried to get him on
I don't know. It's cuz it was the it was the Trump thing, right?
Sorry if you just said this. Um like it was the like Destiny
had the quotes about how he wanted Trump to get shot like actually
and Andrew Wilson was trying to farm those as well. Felt like
um they're all kind of prepared like just prepared to go after
him. Did you see the Chen Destiny exchange from today? The most
disgusting person. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Yeah. What else
do we even have happen today? Trying to look for next >> tone
exchange as well.
Was there I think I saw that on Tech's Twitter work. You steal
man's argument without being totally uncharitable.
>> No, it is it is literally blackmail. It is literally
blackmail. He's saying you you can fix your behavior. I won't
I won't disavow this bad thing that happened until you fix your
behavior because I want you because he said I literally want
you to be pressured by the violence by the the threat of being
killed and to change your position. That's what do you mean steelman
that drama 101? Is this a food shop alt? Um can you steal man
me? Can you Can you steal me, bro? Make a argument first.
see here. Same white guys who spent years making George Floyd
jokes, getting instantly radicalized, seeing another white person
die on camera. >> I
doubt you want to see the new Sam Hyde video, but there's a Sam
Hyde video. >> I mean, he's just calling I feel like he's
just calling for a race war.
>> He's literally just calling for a race
>> Saddle from I mean, allegedly. >> Oh, Jesus. Same
white guys who spent years being good children instantly radicalized
the moment they see their father sucking another man's Jesus
Christ. Did Techtown really come back with that? That's uh >> Destiny
came back again. Nah,
>> mate. Your father was a prolific harasser in the military.
Please calm the [__] Dude, that's so weak. That's
so He's actually lost his ability. That was maybe the starkkest
thing on the panel on the Piers panel is he has totally lost
his ability to talk. >> It's gone. You don't think the
all caps prolific that doesn't go hard?
>> He's actually
it's fallen off so hard.
>> he had like one or two good >> good digs at Anna
or Jack Pacific I feel like on that panel, but yeah, broadly
it was pretty terrible and and then it doesn't help when Anna
is actually sitting there going like uh you disgusting prick.
You disgusting prick. This is like absolutely this guy. It's
not good, >> dude. It's It is not good. Your kid's father
will be known for in 5 years, but your kid's father will be known
for in 5 years. This one This one would be um >> D's response
to that's okay. Destiny's response is kind of okay. >> Well,
I again I feel like wouldn't this just be something about Tech
being,
>> It goes a little bit of a different direction. It, you
know, there's a little bit of variation.
quote tweet >> not get ripped in prison like yours.
>> Iron Mike does. Okay. Iron Mike going to get ripped
in prison. Iron Mike does. How do we not know this? >> Is
he saying not getting in prison in 5 years because he would be
consenting to
>> Yeah. That's >> I said I said I repost why I said
spicy earlier. I was like I feel like Destiny might be tempting
fate with this one. >> Oh, did you? >> We might be
end up might end up at aging poorly. That'll be like uh
be like the Charlie Kirk tweet about dodging bullets, right?
Be kind of the same >> Yeah. In in 3 weeks after Pam Bondi
is come down this guy. >> Oh, that is basically like all
of these people they're like talking about how are these people
just unaware? They are just unaware, right? Like you guys could
actually just get this guy. Okay. Don't you know this guy confessed
to having child? Miss Bondi. Miss Bondi. Miss Bondi.
Don't you know this guy actually did something? What is this
that Kathy's linking here? Dude, I'm actually seeing what Kman
was talking about. It's so gross. There's so many people saying,
"Why? Why do women not understand the First Amendment? This needs
to get fired. This person needed to have >> resigned.
It's a total swipe."
>> For Trump to be saying the same thing, doubling down
off what she's saying. Like, bro, why are we making this about
women not understanding the First Amendment? The [__]
>> The same thing with Bondi with the Epstein files. I
mean, it's actually Bondie's fault that he find released. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Trump actually totally wanted to release all the evidence
by friends. No, he actually really wanted to do that. The stupid
woman just [__] it up. Okay. And this works on people,
by the way. This like works on people.
>> Like when Trump literally cut off P.
You're still talking about Epstein
>> Like Rob has all of these like reposted all over my
timeline cuz I follow him. >> I mean that guy's a total
fat. >> A what? What? Oh, okay. a lot of people.
>> I mean, his politics are awful.
>> She say, uh, listen, Queen's been reading a lot of the
Counterpoints Twitter. He's a big fan right now. >> Counterpoints
Twitter. I think I've got
>> Dude, I like following Rob Noah cuz randomly he will
just start going hard on Connor and Arerodite. That's funny to
>> Well, he uh Yeah, it was the Connor coming back at him
and just calling him a fat defensive fat like repeatedly. Like
anytime Rob at him now, he's just like, "You're a fat. You're
a fat face."
Conor, Connor, Connor.
>> That's That's literally what I thought you were referring
to. I thought you were just copying what Connor was >> No.
No, I haven't seen that. >> I mean, kind of on the defending
of allegation. I feel like Connor should be a little more careful
with that one, but >> yeah, I wouldn't I wouldn't throw
that >> Yeah. Anyway, >> wrote out the chart. 17
is not is not best. He's given his grounded position on the agent.
It's okay. Yeah. Yeah. >> Yo, Sunday should actually strike
counterpoints for doing the graphs and >> I saw Sunday
went live yesterday, I think. Right. You think he's back to making
content? >> He did a prepared video yesterday about how
you shouldn't celebrate Charlie Kirk's death cuz you look >> Wait,
did he stop making content? I thought he kept making content
the whole time. Did he take a >> He's been around.
>> he demonetized. I can't remember. He's the most his
main channel to be honest.
>> Yeah, he's got a new one. >> No, he's getting
like uh good views on his videos, good views on his streams.
>> Oh my god,
that is >> Oh, President Sunday. >> What a joke.
>> Huh? What? >> Uh, someone got demonetized on YouTube.
The Saint and the Sinner.
>> Oh, right. Yeah. Lost monetization.
>> Can you pull up that thumbnail? I What could have possibly
happened? Who could have demonetized him? Can we scroll his
>> Is it all the videos about Is it all the videos about
>> so much more than But his thumbnail just shows a Palestinian
flag, I think.
>> Or is that
>> half his content? I just don't want to show to people
that are not black cuz he's just >> Marquette Burton. This
honest Muslim tries to school Marquette on the Quran and gets
cooked. >> Wait, wait, go wait. Go, go back. >> Are
you going to videos?
That that one black black overseer. Go the one on that one. The
black overseer like watch the first few >> overseer defends
Charlie Kirk. Marquette teaches him a lesson. I was Jew ones
cuz he's he's got a lot of uh
of Tatum or puppet of Netanyahu in Israel. Netanyah Netanyahu
lying and oppressing. Pull >> pull up Kenny's recommendation.
I've got to see what what happens.
>> Yeah, pull that one up. But scroll back up. You look
you missed the one with the LGBT flag.
And Nick Fuentes.
>> Oh, Nick Fuentes can't keep hiding. This is like him
and D.
>> The thumbnail. >> True. True. Nick's blacks have
low IQ propaganda gets dismantled by Marquette. This guy had
massive videos though. He was getting way bigger videos. I thought
he's getting like hundreds of thousands of views doing like anti-Semitic
content. I crazy. I thought he had like big videos on here. Yeah.
Two months >> Tells Why Israel is the true terrorist state.
Yeah, this is what I thought he was getting. Did he Did he add
this to the thumbnail?
Did he like AI this guy to add the the hat and the Jesus Christ?
>> Okay. Okay. I want to go back on Go back on like the
Black Overse videos. >> Yeah, let's watch one >> latest
latest go that one. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Go 9 minutes 37 seconds. >> 9 minutes 37 seconds.
Let's go. And as much as that is the case, you are just as dangerous
as Charlie Kirk, >> who is just as dangerous as Adolf Hitler.
To be the one who is the enslaver, clearly dangerous
to be the one who is the overseer for the enslaver. Oo, insidious.
Nasty work. It's nasty work because some people might look at
you Adi or whatever. I don't know. You're Nigerian. I You're
You're not You're not white. You don't have a white name. I can't
say your name cuz it's not white. It's like Nigerian. So since
we're not Nigeria, I'll just pretend as I can't pronounce it
since I'm a white sup. Um, so people like >> you censored
supremacist. Okay. >> You
nasty work cuz some black >> Wait, didn't he debunk the
IQ point in a different video? I thought he debunked this that
the Okay. Why is he white supremacist if it's not supremacist
if it's not over IQ? What? >> Might look at you and think
you're one of them. But really, you're one of me. You're my spawn.
You're my creation.
And I appreciate you. Are you a Christian? >> Um, yeah.
>> Exactly. Exactly. Thank you. Does your mom have a white
Jesus in her house? Picture. Be honest. Be honest. Somewhere
you've seen a white Jesus in your mom's house. Be honest. >> No.
But would you go to church? I mean, >> okay. The white
Jesus in is in your church. Okay. Very nice. But you don't think
your mom has a white Jesus anywhere in the house? No, not that.
>> That's a Damn it. We didn't get you as good as we could
have. But you go to church Sundays and you worship a white Jesus,
right? >> I mean, Christianity was there before. >> No,
I'm just asking. I'm just asking. In your church, in your church,
is there a white Jesus? >> No, there's not a picture of
white Jesus. Is >> I mean, you said you don't have to start
lying now. You just said that there was a white Jesus. Not
>> there's no white Jesus, but I I know the >> Ah,
I thought we had you all the way. I thought we had you all the
way. I know. >> Cuz our our effort our effort is to rob
you
of what you are. We don't want you to follow the ism. Be yourself.
Be good to yourself. Be good to good people. Be yourself. We
don't want you to know who you are. We want you to be just like
us. If you have a unique name, like a Nigerian name, we want
you to have a name like John, Paul, James, you know, a white
biblical name, an English name, an anglicized name. And if your
name is not one of those things, and we will pretend as though
we cannot pronounce it.
So, what is your name? What's your name? >> There hella
names in the Bible. I can't
>> No, your name is Toby. What is your
>> No, your name is Toby. What is your >> I'm I'm
telling you. I know. >> It's Toby. It's Toby. Just Toby.
>> Get the whip. Get the whip. This going to act up.
>> I mean, do you think Do you think that you are acting
like that when you get >> Toby. One second. Toby. One second.
>> Not a good whip crack sound. [__] Hold >> Do
not. >> You You live in the UK, bro.
>> You're a Christian just like the whites in the UK, bro.
You dress like them. Uh, what was your relig like? What's your
your tribe? Was it IU? Ebo.
>> Euroba. Nice. Euroba. What was their religion before
Christianity
or Islam? >> James. I think it was some form of
>> You think you think
>> looked into it? >> You haven't looked into it.
Oh, so what you're saying is Marquet, you're right. They've separated
me from what I am. You You maybe don't have to follow it, but
damn, you don't even know. You don't even know the history of
your people. And I'll tell you why it's so sad, Toby. Toby, it's
very very sad. Because the blacks were ripped away from their
history. And they were forced
forced not to know their history. It was robbed of them knowledge
of self. You voluntarily decided to not know who you are, Toby.
And the reason you don't know your own religion is cuz you've
taken out the time to learn my religion. Me, I'm Charlie Kirk,
the white, you know, the Christian. Uh, and you've taken out
time to study my religion, but you didn't study your own. That's
fascinating. Toby, do you speak Euroba?
>> Toby. Toby. So, you're telling me in 2025 where you
could very much So, >> how' this guy get demonetized, though?
But be for real. How'd he get demonetized? have like a second
language, you know, speak Euroba and English. You're like, "Ah,
my my history. Ah, it's irrelevant. I don't need that. I don't
need to know my own religion. I don't need to know the history
of the land from which I come. I don't need to speak the language
of my forefathers. I'd rather just pretend they don't exist."
Toby.
Toby, you are me. Say it with me. I am
>> I mean, I understand what you're saying. >> No,
no, no, no, no, no. Just say it. I am white. >> Okay, just
real quick. Okay, try this. Try this. This might feel better.
This might feel better. Say, I am a white
>> I'm not. >> No, you are. You are, Toby. Say it.
I am a white sup. >> How is criticizing I mean >> Oh
gosh. That's a I'm just trying to get you, Toby. I'm just trying
to get you to the truth. >> I mean, I'm I'm being >> You
are Lord and Savior Jesus Christ. The truth, the light, and the
the something else people too. It doesn't make you a overseer
or white just
>> I mean you criticize black people too like trying to
make >> I do criticize black people Toby. But you know
what I don't do? Do you know what I don't do, Toby?
>> I don't come on as a mouthpiece for white supremacists
who hate black >> Okay, next. >> That's number one.
Toby. >> Next. Stop only hating on black people. Do one
when he on a >> I don't watch those ones.
>> I would just go to Fentes. Why would I watch the internet
and I just go to >> Where's the one where he kicks someone
off? This guy
Marquette is like insanely
>> Which one are we watching? >> Uh, scroll down.
He like kicks someone off. Or the I guess the font one. >> One
of these popular ones.
Oh, yeah. He did a thing with Analysia, right? Watching Analysia.
>> Oh, yeah. It's from like a year ago. >> Traditional
grandmouth
single mom who thinks she knows it all. sneaky ways women cheat.
Understanding
>> I think he could get demonetized just for a lot of the
that he says about >> Um there's one time
>> one where he's talking about Egyptians. This went crazy.
>> What are we doing here? Someone's got to make a call.
Oh, Dr. Dr. Umar is an obese feminist who must be stopped.
>> Oh my goodness. >> Uh Hatchet David is a disgusting
Israeli >> Kenny, what's that one that you sent me a while
ago about about the Uh, in the United Nations, you have 180 countries,
190 countries. >> I think it's the one where he kicks off
>> person. If you're talking about the one that you watch
on stream, cuz I started watching this guy's YouTube after I
saw Queen cover it. >> Yeah, I think I watched on stream.
Um, >> tells a why Israel is the true terror state. 377K.
>> No, that's not one.
Okay. Where's his channel? I mean, I'm kind of with Kenny here
where it's just like, you know, I if I want to watch someone
be racist to people, I've already got a content creator for that.
He's kind of perfected it. Kind of like massive kind of getting
150,000 viewers concurrent. So,
you know, don't really don't really need to bother here. Okay.
Um, you guys sound like a fan. >> I can't I can't see the
link. >> Kenny, what what was the video? Do you remember
what it's called?
>> What's the video about? >> It was like It's got
a call in with some who like freaks out. It's got like some title
like goes crazy or some stupid [__] like that. You
would have sent it to me like within the last two months I >> Then
I definitely don't know what that's that guy is gone. >> He's
got one where he's calling Adam Sausnik straight up evil. That's
11 minutes. That might be interesting. >> S
dude
Sausnik's like annoying. I don't even know how you could call
him evil. Does he do anything that could be considered evil?
>> I DM Oh, wait. That's not right. >> It's a law
now. If you ran a country from start, would you be okay with
gay >> Oh, you got it. >> adopting kids. >> It
wouldn't be my first order of >> bro. Get their knowledge.
>> That's Bro,
>> listen.
I'm glad I'm not there. I would have caught a >> The way
he screamed yes or no. I'm sorry. That's like It instantly makes
me think of Pisco. >> Oh, I didn't. Yeah. Okay. >> Case.
I would have caught a case. I would have caught a case cuz I
might have been tempted to do God's work. As soon as PBD and
PBD Fruity is damn as soon as PBD Fruity ass
would you be okay
if there was Skittleg guzzling
prevailing in the land prevalent in the land and bro start coping
please instead of saying yes or no
I might have lost it. Oh man
down the bro is bro is speechless. Is he trying to get his lies
together? This is how you know you're dealing with a devil. Honest
men can speak in strong words. Yes. No.
Principles.
These liars, they got to think. They got to look up. They got
to ponder. They got to look up like the answers in the sky. They
got to think twice. They got to equivocate. They got to rephrase
and reformulate.
Lies are complex. The truth is simple. Come on now.
Listen to this devil right here. men
adopting kids. >> Listen to this devil. >> It wouldn't
be my first order of >> Bro, we didn't ask you that.
>> Down the list. >> I don't want any trans weird
because
we ain't ask you about that, boy. You're dodging like politicians
do.
>> Wait, why are you calling gay people >> No, I'm
saying Marquette is gross. >> Like, this is slop content.
>> You found it. Found it. >> Nice. Yeah, I found
it. Wait, why isn't Can you link it to me, bro? You put in the
log. >> Come on. Come on.
>> Here we go. Video's been removed for violating YouTube's
terms of service. >> Yeah, this might be what
>> might be. That's why you can't find it. >> Okay.
Well, GG. >> That definitely did nothing.
>> I linked you one as well. I don't know if we need to
watch
talked about weird.
I'll watch it.
like me myself, yeah, but as like you know, you can't speak as
as white because there are that are black.
You should know that, right? >> There have I do know that
there were Ethiopian Jews uh who in some cases were airlifted
into Israel. I am also aware that the Israeli government sterilized
a great many of the women. You familiar with that? Yeah, this
is a government. >> Dude, that's the worst answer I've
ever
Okay. Okay. If we're um after this, I might pull up the what
do you call it? The
you go through both of the Dan Loaderbox moments. Might go look
for time stamps on those. >> Aware that the Israeli government
sterilized a great many of the women. You familiar with that?
>> Yeah. This is a government like
yes and no, I guess.
Well, yes and no don't make sense together. That would be like
saying I'm both pregnant and not pregnant at the same time. So,
the answer is yes. Yes, it happened. Yes, you're aware of it.
But you're about to say that that's uh the government, not the
people. >> Yeah, because because there's like listen because
there's also another case about disappearing uh what do you call
it? Uh Yemen kids, right? After they they made aliyah here from
Yemen. >> Okay. because after um the establishment of the
state uh they flew Yemen from Yemen to here and some of them
also went missing like you hear a story here and there. So there
always conspiracies behind the
uh the curtains but
uh the the the fact on the matters is that we are mixed together.
>> I agree that there's >> scale doesn't matter to
this guy this guy. Yes, I agree that there's an idea that they're
different uh tribes and as a result they look different and they're
obviously racially different. But I'm saying that the Ethiopian
Jews uh some of which were airlifted into Israel
uh they were ster some of them were sterilized by the government.
That is a fact right that we agree on. >> I don't know
if it's sterilized. I have I myself haven't heard uh this this
specific story myself because I know a lot. I have I myself have
Iopan friends and I never heard of this before. Maybe it is true,
maybe not. But maybe you can refer to a case. I will be happy
to. >> Yeah. And I'm not trying to put you on the spot.
I just think these are very important things to acknowledge.
So here it is. Ethiopian women in Israel giving contraceptive
without consent. And this is like the most pleasant, nice way
of saying it. Um, Ethiopian immigrants have unwittingly had deproa
jabs for years, meaning without their permission, being injected
with a controversial contraceptive without their knowledge, which
is to say uh an attempt to sterilize and or >> I'm going
to go find this uh Dan K. This is actually This is like I'm guessing
there are better moments. I'm guessing he pops off in other moments.
Okay, this is uh >> Yeah, I don't know which one's the
one where he talks about the lady that gave a baby herpes by
circumcising the baby with her mouth. >> Uh, gross. >> That
was insane. I cannot say that that's true or not, but it's obviously
like it's true. It's like one person did it, so it's just like
I don't know. He's like rage bait type of [__] channel.
>> No, that's like a common thing. >> They commonly
give babies herpes. That's what you're saying, Queenman. >> Yeah.
Well, basically, yeah, because they do the commonly bite.
They bite. >> They bite the baby and it does result in
infection sometimes. And that is herpes. Like, you know, a nonzero
amount of >> Yeah. A nonzero. You're not telling me that
in your country >> they always giving babies her >> are
doing circumcisions.
>> Whoa, whoa, whoa. No. In the UK, people other than like
super hardcore doing circumcision here. just American thing.
>> I found I count I found one of the learner box sessions,
but that's like an 8 hour conversation. That's not as long as
the one from today.